anthony blinken hier à berlin
aujourd'hui il est à paris le secrétaire
d'état américain s'est entretenu avec
jean yves le drian n'en rencontre
amicale qui a permis d'évoquer de
nombreux sujets les précisions de notre
reporter devant le quai d'orsay 4 sa
technique
la conférence était dense avec de
nombreux points abordés jean yves le
drian a salué un nouvel élan le retour
sur des valeurs partagées sur l'exigence
de la démocratie et sur le
multilatéralisme qu'ils ont la
responsabilité de poursuivre
l'europe et les américains doivent être
unis il a rappelé que l'europe avait été
bien seul durant quatre ans pour se
battre contre les attaques de la
démocratie il se félicite de travailler
de nouveau ensemble et souhaite un
approfondissement de la relation
bilatérale
je vous propose d'écouter jean yves le
drian depuis le début de l'année avec
anthony blinken nous sommes employés à
nourrir ce nouvel élan en remuant un
dialogue constant et confiant constant
et confiant qui est indispensable entre
nos deux pays est indispensable parce
que les défis immenses auxquels nous
sommes confrontés exige toute notre
énergie que soit la pandémie lovers
climatique en passant par les inégalités
mondiales indispensable parce que nous
traversons un grave moment de
brutalisation de la vie internationale
et c'est pourquoi l'approfondissement de
notre alliance est un impératif
stratégique que nous agissions at-il
bilatérales ou au sein de la relation
union européenne états unis ou encore
dans le cadre d'une otan rééquilibrer où
les européens se donnent désormais des
moyens de jouer pleinement leur rôle
ce que le président by dane et vous même
avez salué nous sommes plus forts
ensemble
anthony blinken a parlé de la france
comme de la plus vieil allié de l'allié
idéal pour remporter les grands défis
d'un partenariat indispensable encore
plus important aujourd'hui on écoute le
secrétaire d'état américain
il est plus impérative que jamais de
travailler ensemble pour relever les
défis de ce moment qu'ils ont vraiment
un impact sur la vie de nos citoyens
aucun de nous ne peut le faire seul nous
sommes tellement plus fort et plus
efficace lorsque nous travaillons
ensemble et le président joe biden est
extrêmement reconnaissant et heureux du
partenariat que nous avons avec la
france
je pense qu'ensemble nous avons
l'opportunité de démontrer que nos
démocraties peuvent produire de vrais
résultats pour notre peuple et pour les
gens du monde entier et je suis
reconnaissant de pouvoir travailler avec
vous dans cette direction alors merci de
nous accueillir aujourd'hui outre la
coopération culturelle et commerciale
les deux hommes ont cité les défis
contemporains que son l'urgence
climatique et la pandémie ainsi que la
sécurité au sahel avec la lutte contre
le terrorisme
les américains vont continuer à soutenir
la france et les pays africains
concernés
les deux hommes semblaient également
aligné sur l'attitude face à la chine
vue par jean yves le drian comme un
partenaire un concurrent mais aussi un
rival
anthony blinken on le sait recherche le
soutien accru de l'europe pour organiser
la riposte contre la chine accusée de
saper l'ordre commercial mondial